LINDSAY METCALFE:
Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our talk
"Designing for Daydream."
How many people here
attended a VR talk yesterday?
It's really great to see this.
It's so nice to see so many
people who have been designing
VR for a while, and who are just
really excited about everything
we're doing here at IO, and
then people who are just getting
started.
So for Daydream,
our goal here is
enabling very high
quality mobile VR,
all the way from like
hardware up through the stock
to the user experience.
So we really want to make
sure that we're giving you
everything that you need to
create really compelling VR
immersive experiences.
And we've talked a lot
this week about everything
from hardware optimizations
to developer tools.
And we had some great
talks yesterday too.
So yesterday we talked
about VR filmmaking.
We had a really
great talk on lessons
learned from design labs from
our rapid prototyping team.
And you can watch all
of this on YouTube
if you missed any of this.
And so today we want to go
a bit deeper in designing
for Daydream and talk all
about the key ingredients
and considerations for
designing for Daydream.
So really, what's
important for creating
great VR content
that's comfortable,
engaging but also unique?
And to do this we're going
to walk you through four
different lightning talks.
So the first of these, at
the center of the experience,
we're going to take a
look at your audience.
So who are you designing for ?
What do we know
about them already?
And what of that
can help you create
the very best content for them?
And then we're going to take
a look at the ergonomics
of that user in VR.
So what are the important
considerations and constraints
that can give you a
starting point for designing
and prototyping.
In VR?
Next, creating a
feeling of presence
and being able to transport
people to different realities
is really key to grafting VR.
So we're going to
talk you through
why crafting the right
environment is important,
and also how to get it right.
And then finally, we're
to explore something else
that's also really important
for presence, which is input,
and how you can use a
world of interactions
that are made possible with
our Daydream controller.
And now I'm going to
hand this over to Dave,
and he's going to talk to
you about your audience.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID DEARMAN: Thanks, Lindsay.
So over the past
year, Google's VR team
has been doing a lot of
research to better understand
how people are using
high end mobile devices.
Whoops.
I skipped ahead.
How people are using
high end mobile devices,
but also how we can make VR
a part of our daily life.
And today I want to
share three insights
from that research
with you that I
think will help us build
better experiences.
And the first insight from
the research that we took away
was that VR is really compelling
to a broad number of people
and for many, many
different reasons.
There's a large audience of
people who want to get into VR.
And what they told
us when we talked
to them was that VR is
really this great gateway
to enable them to have
new experiences, new forms
of entertainment, also
change their perspective
and how they might see
things, but also give them
new abilities-- whether
it be superhuman abilities
or super powers-- to do
things they couldn't actually
do in real life.
And I want to go through
a couple of these.
So the first is gaming.
Gaming is a powerful
opportunity for VR,
and not just hardcore gaming.
All types of gaming.
So let's take an example
here: my golf game.
I love to play golf.
Traditionally, a
golf game, you would
have sort of the third
person perspective.
You'd see the person
swinging their club,
you control it
with a controller.
But with VR, the controller
can become your putter.
You can take on the
perspective of that golfer.
So you can line
up over that putt.
You can actually make it and
see the ball go in the hole.
That's a really
compelling perspective.
Next, personal cinema.
VR can become your
own personal cinema.
If you're watching a video,
a movie, binging on TV shows,
you don't need to be constrained
to a small little screen
anymore.
Whether your screen is
30 inches, 60 inches,
even 100 inches.
VR can immerse people
in that content.
So rather than seeing
those raindrops sort
of trickling down on your
screen 10 feet in front of you,
you can actually feel
those raindrops are
going to hit that leaf
and sort of bounce
off and hit you, because you're
kind of in the content itself.
VR can also take people to
new places, places that we
kind of only dream about.
I would love to become
an astronaut, tour space,
find a new places.
Probably not going to
happen in my lifetime.
Maybe it will.
But in VR, we can all
become that space explorer.
We can all go to Mars.
In sort of the snap
of our fingers,
we can be teleported there.
We could be standing
next to the Rover,
or even exploring other planets
that maybe we haven't even
discovered yet.
VR also provides a more intimate
way to bring people together.
More so than say traditional
communication technologies.
You know, daily life doesn't
afford us the ability
to be around the people
that we care about,
whether it's our loved
ones, friends, colleagues,
acquaintances.
VR can bring people together
across distance and time.
And it could put us in
that virtual coffee shop
where we could
interact with objects.
We could sit side by side.
It could be the next
best thing to actually
having that face to face
conversation that real life may
not afford us at that time.
There's also huge
learning opportunities.
VR can be sort of
the premier place
to learn and also to sort
of have personal growth.
Imagine this engine here.
In VR, I could take that engine
apart with a wave in my hand.
I could see how all the
pieces come together.
I could see all the steps
and how I might assemble it.
That might be really
difficult in real life.
And it's also, if
I make a mistake,
it could be really effortful
to undo that mistake.
But in VR, you could
undo that really easy.
Try again.
It didn't work.
I could undo it and try again.
You could make experiential
learning really easy.
And on the flip
side of that coin,
there's also
experiential creation.
VR can become the premier
place for self-expression
or creativity.
It's a place where I
could create and craft
my masterpiece.
You have control over the
palette, the color, the tools,
the perspective, the size.
If I want to make my thing
small, I can make it small.
But I could very easily then
grow it and make it larger.
That's something you really
can't do in real life
very easily.
But in VR you can.
The only limitation
really here is the tools
that we provide people
and their imagination.
And finally, access to
professional services
and professionals themselves.
Throughout our
life, we need access
to people who can
help us do things.
For example, buying a home.
You typically reach out to
a real estate professional
to help you do that task.
They can guide you
through the process,
help you understand
all the rules,
take you from place to place.
But doing that in real life,
that can be quite effortful.
It takes a full
afternoon, a weekend
to go visit five
different homes, five
different rentals that you're
thinking of getting into.
But with a snap
of a finger in VR,
the real estate agent
could take you from A to B
to C. They could take you to
20 places in the same time
that you could drive
between three or four.
What's also interesting
about this case,
sort of looking
at AR VR together,
is that I could visit
this blank home.
And they could change all
the content in that space
to match my style.
Rather than walking
into a staged home that
doesn't meet what I would
typically want to move into,
so it doesn't really
resonate with me.
Or just an empty space.
An agent could take that space
and put all my stuff in it.
And be like, this
actually does feel
like a space I could live in.
So beyond motivations and sort
of aspirational expectations,
we also learned a little
bit about how people
are using these devices today.
And one of the things that
we found inspirational
is that people are using a
lot of these devices not just
for snackable moments.
Snackable moments typically you
might associate with a phone.
You pull your phone
out of your pocket,
you respond to a text
message, you read an e-mail,
check a stock quote.
And then you put it back
in your pocket and move
on with your day.
You keep sipping your coffee.
That's a snackable moment.
But VR can be like a really
good compelling book.
As long as the content
is good and entertaining,
it can really keep people's
attention drawn into it.
So for example, if
someone's playing a game
or visiting new places,
and that content really
has them attached,
people have told us
that they can be in a session
for 30 or more minutes.
If they're binging on TV shows
or they're watching a movie,
what people told
us is that sessions
can be 90 minutes or longer.
What's really important here
is the quality of that content,
the content itself,
and that's what's
going to keep people engaged.
And also their comfort
during that experience.
Finally, the third
point, speaking
of comfort, what we learned from
people when we talked to them
was that most of the time,
even though these devices
are portable-- our
phone's portable.
Our headset's portable.
You can put it in a bag or
purse and take it with you.
A lot of people are using
these devices primarily
in their home,
seated comfortably.
So when we did in home visits
with people, what a lot of them
actually showed
us is they kind of
have a comfy spot, a comfy
spot where they sort of use
their VR headset.
Whether that company spot
was a couch, a favorite seat,
or laying on their bed, what
was clear from the conversations
with them and what
they showed us
was that standing
really wasn't something
that they did a lot of.
It gets tiring to stand
up for 30 minutes.
It especially gets
tiring standing up
trying to watch a
90 minute video.
It's something they would
do sort of comfortably
relaxed laying down.
And I think this is
an important point
to bring up because a
lot of the experiences
that we're going
to be building, we
need to recognize that
people aren't necessarily
going to be standing up
and moving around a lot.
They're probably going
to be seated comfortably.
And that's something we need
to take into account when
we're actually building
something for them.
And on that note,
I'm going to hand off
to Mike who will
talk about building
comfortable virtual experiences.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE ALGER: So VR can seem
like an intimidating medium
to design for, because
you can do so much.
So constraints can be nice
to use as starting points.
The limits of your body is
one of those constraints
to start with.
Digital designers are
used to thinking about
how the eye is guided
through things,
or how the thumb can reach where
easily on a phone, for example.
When you're designing
for Daydream,
you can think about how
someone's moving their head,
how much of the
scene they can see,
and how far away things are.
Since you're probably used
to working with an art
board or canvas, you can
think about how much they
move as your new boundaries.
If it's a standing thing, they
can go all the way around.
They just can see a
certain amount at a time.
What they see kind of looks
like a cone from the side.
But if we look at it from their
point of view, it's a circle.
If you have a UI panel
covering more than 70 degrees
of that field of view,
or 35 to each side,
then it starts to feel like
the theater screen is as
much as you could even look at.
For reference an IMAX
screen from the middle seat
is 70 degrees.
If the user is sitting
in a stationary chair,
like their couch, then there's
boundaries to how far they'll
comfortably move their neck.
They can easily go all the way
to 80 degrees to each side,
but 30 was kind of a comfortable
center point left and right.
If you really stretch,
you can put stuff further,
but remember that they'll
have to strain their neck
or change their posture and
turn their shoulders if it's
too far, and they're
sitting on a couch.
Vertically, you tend
to look down a little,
like 15 degrees
from the horizon.
But it depends more
on your posture.
Like reclining in a seat,
you can't look down as far
because your neck is there.
So with those constraints,
you've got a field of view
and a range of motion.
And that's one way to think
about what you're canvass is.
Things can be placed all
over the range of motion,
but the user will only
be able to see what's
in the field of view at a time.
We also add depth to that.
Too close in, like a half meter,
for too long is uncomfortable
because it feels like
it's up in your face.
You might think that
you want to put things
right next to your
face, like a helmet,
but you'll find
pretty quick that it
makes you have to go
cross-eyed to even see it.
Too far, past 20 meters,
and you can't really
see the difference
in depth very easily.
So most of your main
content and UI stuff
will fall within
this zone here where
depth is meaningful
and comfortable to see.
By the way, to help
people understand
the depth between objects,
shadows and imperfections
in the texture are
really important.
So if you have subtle
noise in your textures
and represent light
realistically,
it will really help give
your users more cues
to understand depth in the
way that their brains were
wired to automatically.
The reason is the imperfections
give your eyes something
to converge on.
Without them, a large
flat color might
look like an infinite
void of that color.
Watching this, you can
see the little specks
on your screen surface,
and you perceive its depth.
But in VR, you don't have that.
So the importance of shadows
is something that we already
knew from material design.
But the necessity of subtle
texture noise is unique to VR.
If you're creating UI, it's also
helpful to know that resolution
is a major constraint.
As they said at
the last IO, it's
more useful to talk
about resolution
in terms of pixels per degree.
You can approximate how
many pixels on the screen
fit in one degree of your
field of view near the center.
It's reasonable to
expect that resolution
will increase over time.
But for now we
have the situation
where aliasing makes hard
edges and thin lines dance
and sparkle distractingly.
More anti-aliasing looks better,
but can hurt your performance.
So that's an interesting
design constraint
to give yourself, trying
to avoid high contrast
edges and thin lines.
That also begs the question
of how big to make text
so that you can still read it.
How small is too small?
As time goes on and more
pixels get packed in,
you'll be able to read smaller
text until you eventually
get to 20/20 vision.
Which, you could say
is in the ballpark
of 60 pixels per degree.
But current VR headsets
are only around 10
to maybe 13 pixels per degree.
As pixels per degree increases,
your text can be smaller.
There's barely readable and then
there's comfortably readable.
Right now your starting
point is about 1.5 degrees
of that field of view.
Of course, it'll
be smaller later
as companies smash
more pixels in,
and VR approaches,
hopefully, 20/20 vision.
But that's the
end of this graph.
But for now, this is kind of a
lot of information to take in.
So it's easier to just say
that basically text needs
to be more than 14 pixels
tall on the display
before your brain can even
tell what letters the pixels
are making.
And at around 20
pixels is comfortable,
regardless of the device.
So this was gotten using rubato
at the center of the view
and with a text rendering method
called signed distance field.
Different contrast ratios,
optics, rendering methods,
font weights, and type faces
will be a little different.
But saying 20 pixels
tall is an easy way
to give designers a ballpark
baseline to start with.
In a game engine, you don't
really think in pixels, though.
You measure in terms of
meters and millimeters.
So this is a
developer conference,
so I'll feel a little more safe
in throwing out this equation
and saying that you can figure
out the text height in the game
engine as a relationship
between the distance
to the virtual text, the number
of pixels tall you want it,
and the pixels per
degree of the device.
So if you want text 20
pixels high on a device
with 13 pixels per degree,
you can take the distance
to the text and
multiply it by 0.027
to get its starting height.
That's about 1.5 degrees
tall from that graph earlier.
And for those of
you who don't want
to bother with an equation,
it's fine to just ignore
that and take the
distance and multiply it
by 0.027 to get its height.
And then just look at it in the
headset and see what you think.
So now you have a base text
size in a basic canvas of field
of view and range of motion.
These numbers are pretty
conservative and rounded
because the purpose is to give
designers a baseline for VR.
It's like when you
open a new document,
and you have the default paper
dimensions and font size.
With those things
put together, you
can start imagining the types of
interfaces you can make in VR.
You can change the canvas, and
you can change the text size,
but hopefully it's helpful to at
least have that starting point
to begin working with.
And it makes sense
because it's based
on the constraints
of the system, which
are properties of the device and
properties of the humans using
them.
So I've given you some
suggestions for the user
interface, but there's also the
environment that it lives in.
Brian will explain his
thoughts on designing
beautiful environments for VR.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN PULLEN: Thanks, Mike.
Every VR application needs
at least one environment.
And that might seem
obvious for VR games,
but it's not as obvious
for other non-game types
of applications.
Today I want to tell you why
these environments are still
very important,
and really give you
some advice on how
to create them.
Now, in addition
to just being cool,
a great environment is actually
central to a user's sense
of presence.
Maintaining presence
in your applications
really should always
be a top priority.
If done right, an environment
helps your users better
understand your application.
It engages them more, and
it makes your product more
memorable and more shareable.
Now there's already
been a lot written
on presence and the value
of it, so if you're not
familiar with that concept, I
encourage you to look it up.
Now the primary value of VR is
the ability to take you places.
So I'm advocating for taking
your users to amazing places.
Create destinations that
your users want to visit
and want to show to others.
You've got to make
it remarkable.
Now your environment is often
the first thing your user sees.
It takes up the
majority of their field
of view at all times.
And it's a key
part of how they're
going to think of your
app, how they're going
to remember it and describe it.
It's also a physical embodiment
of your company's brand.
So you have to consider
how it represents you.
Don't think of the
environment simply
as a wallpaper or a background.
Think of it as the destination
that your users are going to.
Now I see a lot of
applications creating
these void style environments.
Now I understand why.
They're fast.
They're easy to make.
They have great performance.
And if you don't
have an obvious idea,
they might seem like
a good fallback.
In my opinion, I think
that you should not make
a void your main environment.
I think it's a missed
opportunity to create something
memorable and sharable.
I wouldn't want all my memories
of being in your application
to be in this
strange void space.
Now if you are out of ideas,
and maybe low on 3D skills,
or concerned about
performance, maybe
think about creating an
abstract environment.
It's a step up from a
void, and it can still
be branded and memorable.
Now there is no place
I have ever been
that is completely soundless.
And in fact, much of the
experience of any environment
is its sounds.
Your sound design should start
right along your visual design,
right at the beginning.
And one can even
influence the other.
You could decide to put
something into the audio
that you decide
not to visualize.
Maybe you can only
hear the birds
but not actually see
them, or vice versa.
It's also the easiest way to
annoy your users if done wrong.
So be careful with
repetitive sounds or things
that sound fake
or volume levels.
And in fact, getting
sound right in VR
is really quite challenging
and not obvious at all.
There's been a lot said
about sound in VR recently,
particularly this year at GDC.
So I encourage you to look that
up if you haven't seen it yet.
It's surprisingly easy to make
people feel uncomfortable in VR
environments.
Little things like a room
that is a little messy
or has things out
of place can make
users feel powerless and really
annoyed by your environment.
More obviously, you should
try not to scare people.
Elements like dark hallways
with this mist coming out of it,
or partly open doors that
you don't know what's
behind them, or
heights, things like
that-- they can all
make users uncomfortable
and not want to spend
time in your app.
But it can be worse than that.
You need to really
be aware of phobias.
This underwater environment
might seem really cool,
but there are some users
so terrified of water
that the second they
come to this app they'll
rip the headset off
and never come back.
Right?
So this is something you
really need to watch out for.
Now your environment should
be designed with your UI,
with your content, in mind.
It should frame it
not fight against it.
Now a detailed environment
is really great,
but don't let it hurt the
usability of your application.
Avoid noisy edges
or busy content
getting in the way
of the readability
or making it clear
to see the content.
Now think about how
your UI might even
scroll or animate and make
sure it doesn't conflict
with the environment, you
know, clip through things
or become obscured.
In this mock up,
I used this rock
to actually frame
the navigation.
It protects the text.
It creates some
visual hierarchy.
It also-- I allow the
light and the clearing
to frame the background
content and make it the focus.
And it's got that
kind of difference
in lighting to say this
is where the content is.
This is a navigation.
So you can design
your environments
to really showcase your content.
And I don't like to think of
the UI and environment as two
separate elements, conceptually.
Make them feel connected.
Make them feel like
they live in one world,
like it's plausibly
existing together.
Use things like colors
and lighting, shadows,
even reflections, animations,
physics-- all of these things
allow you to connect your
UI to your environment more.
And you can even
allow the environment
to occlude, sometimes hide parts
the environment or the content,
while you're scrolling perhaps.
Now a living environment is much
more interesting and much more
believable than a static one.
There's a lot of things
that you can bring to life.
Think of wind, water, animals,
plants, the dust in the air,
the light coming
through the trees,
clouds, people, machines--
the opportunities
are endless for animation.
And it's about more
than just animation.
It's about giving
users the ability
to interact and to
affect to the world.
They need to feel like
they exist in that world.
Maybe if they have a
little laser pointer
that they used to
touch the UI, maybe
they can use that to
create ripples in a pond
or to move the leaves or
scare away a squirrel.
Something like that would
actually be really delightful,
and it makes the user feel
present in that virtual world.
Now creating detailed animations
can be really hard, really
time consuming, if you
don't have those skills.
An easy way to get
that experience
is to use particle effects.
Things like dust
motes, falling leaves,
fireflies-- these things are
cheap and easy to create.
One of these effects
might take two or three
minutes to create, even
for an experienced person.
And it does a lot to
bring the scene to life.
It also gives you a
strong sense of stereo 3D
as these things move in
and out of your near field.
Where practical, I use particle
effects in every environment.
Now details in
the foreground are
the ones that really
stand out because
of that sense of stereo 3D.
As such, I usually
try to ensure that I
have a good amount
of details up close,
and that I build them
at a real geometry
so they have some substance,
that they feel solid and real.
Of course, beyond 20 meters,
you really lose that effect.
And so I encourage you
to down res everything.
Get rid of the polygons to
really save on performance.
You should also be careful
about creating environments
that are going to alias poorly.
In fact, this jungle here has
all those very fine leaves.
This is going to
alias like crazy.
In fact, when you look
at this in a VR headset,
it's just going to sparkle.
The whole thing will be
sparkling at all times.
And it's going to be
extremely distracting,
maybe even uncomfortable.
The most important thing you
can do for your environment
is ensure that it performs well.
A fluctuating frame weight
will make people sick.
And a detailed environment
is almost always
challenging to optimize.
Now if I'm going to give you
one piece of advice on designing
your environment, remember
that your mobile phone
is fill bound.
Try not to do too much
overdraw or transparency.
That is the thing that's
going to kill you first.
But keep your draw calls low.
Keep your poly count low.
And try not to max
out the performance
of the phone at all times.
If you're an app where you
want people to watch video
for two hours, but your
environment is so detailed
that it's running the phone
at maximum performance,
that's going to be challenging.
Now an interesting fallback
is a concept called ODS,
Omni-directional stereo images.
Now it's basically a
panoramic image in stereo 3D
that can simulate
a full environment.
Now they don't have
any real time geometry,
and they can have
really great performance
and be easy to create, but
they have some problems.
For one, when you put
your UI into that,
it kind of feels dropped on top.
It just does become
that wallpaper.
It's really hard to
create that connection.
In fact, it's really hard to use
any of the advice I just gave.
You can't animate them.
You can't really
frame things well.
So they're not perfect.
And you also have
to keep in mind
that if you have an application
where users are going
to be turning their
head to the side a lot,
maybe to investigate something,
or for long sessions,
that the stereo effect
actually breaks down
when you tilt your head.
So it might not be
right for everyone.
Now I look forward to visiting
the amazing worlds you create.
It's actually the part of
VR I'm most excited about.
Up next, I want to let Alex
talk about input for Daydream.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX FAABORG: Thanks, Brian.
All right.
The Daydream controller.
The Daydream
controller is actually
included with every
headset, which
we're really excited about.
And also, users have to
use the Daydream controller
as they're interacting
with the home screen.
So as a developer,
you know that when
they launch your
application, they're
going to have this specific
controller in their hand,
so you can design
directly for it.
So let's take a look at it.
It has an internal
IMU, so you can use it
for gesturing and pointing.
And then in terms
of direct input,
you have a two dimensional touch
pad which is also clickable.
It has a sort of
a physical click
in, like a mouse
button would click in.
And then application
developers get an app button.
You can use this for
really whatever you want.
Pause screen, saving your
game, an action inside a game
or inside the application
they're doing.
It's really entirely
up to you how
you want to use the app button.
And then there's a Home button.
And this is reserved by the
system for system actions
like going back to the
launcher, things like that.
And additionally, there's
some volume buttons
on the side that are
reserved by the system.
So, obviously, the first
thing you can do with this
is point and click.
Your users will
initially experience this
as they're interacting
with the home screen.
So as you move the
controller around,
you'll see it actually
activate things
that they're hovering on.
And it sort of behaves
like a laser pointer.
And this is great.
It's very usable.
People can be seated and relaxed
and just by moving their wrist
around they can select things.
But there's really a lot more
you can do with the controller
as well.
And we wanted to be able
to communicate this out
to developers just how
broad the range of things
this controller supports
is and how big that gesture
vocabulary is.
So to do that, we created the
Daydream Design Playground.
This is going to
be open sourced.
Probably in about a week,
after watching this online,
it's likely already
open sourced.
And it has 16 controller
demos, plus or minus a few.
We're still working on it.
So I want to go through
what those demos are
and what you can do
with this controller.
The goal of the Daydream
Design Playground
is to inspire developers to
create entire applications
around these types
of activities.
Maybe not literally
the same thing,
but around these
types of gestures
that are possible
with the controller.
So the first thing you can
do is swinging an object.
That object could
be a tennis racket.
[GLASS TINKLING]
Or that object could
be, say, maybe a really
big hammer in front of
a massive xylophone.
[XYLOPHONE TONES]
Or that object to be a sword.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's, of course, pretty
exciting for the user,
but if they wanted
something more relaxing,
it could be a fishing rod.
[REEL SOUNDS]
[BEEP]
[TRIUMPHANT MUSIC]
The next gesture is
flicking your wrist.
Instead of a full swing, just
a quick motion of your wrist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[EXPLOSION]
One of the seems to be the
most popular demos we've shown
so far is, of course, pancakes.
That remains, an open question
is, can the user actually do
6 pancakes, both flipped
and correctly delivered
onto the plate.
Let's see.
Come on.
Yes!
[APPLAUSE]
But they have them on the plate!
Oh no, they dropped on--
Oh, let's try again.
All right.
It can be a boomerang.
Inspecting an object
is very interesting
with the controller.
In the next example, we
see the controller actually
become the object.
So it starts out
with a quick gesture.
[BRUSHING SOUNDS]
But at this point, the
object and the control
are the same thing.
So as you move the
controller, you
can turn the object in your
hand and see every side of it.
We found this also
works for gameplay.
In this case, the marble
maze and the controller
are the same object.
And as you tilt the
controller, of course,
the marble maze is tilting and
you're controlling the marble.
What's exciting about
this demo is you sort of
even forget you're holding a
controller as you're doing it.
You're just completely
focused on the maze.
And the maze and the controller
really become the same thing.
And you're just
thinking about the goal.
You can also use the
controller to move an object
for environments that
you're creating, if you're
doing user generated content.
Example of that.
Here we're doing laser
points to select.
And then once the object
is picked up with a click,
you can use the touch pad to
actually rotate that object.
You can use the
touch pad to rotate,
to bring it towards you.
In this case, the
user is rotating it
and they're trying to
assemble sort of a 3D puzzle.
So they bring it over here.
Rotate it into the
correct position
as they're trying
to figure it out.
This one is actually a little
bit too hard to start with.
We had to make an
easier puzzle for people
because 3D puzzles are hard.
I'm going to pick
up another one.
I tried another example.
To have a better sense of
sort of scale and power,
here the user is actually
inside a very large crane.
And they're using the
controller to bring the arm out.
Tilt on the controller is
the joystick on the crane.
The touchpad, in
this case, is being
used to operate how close or
far away the statue is from you.
As they bring it over, and then
they push the controller down
to drop the object.
So that was moving objects.
We can also see a lot
of interesting use
in creating objects.
So you could use the
controller to carve things.
Now all those examples
were first person.
But third person is also a
really interesting case for VR.
Real time strategy games.
God games.
Simulations as you look
down upon a game board.
So we wanted to look into
third person character control.
And just as interesting
as first person is for VR,
third person can be really
interesting as well.
So we tried a simple
adventure game,
where you'd go down
and pick up coins.
In this case, the
touchpad on the controller
is being used as kind of a
traditional joystick or D pad
to move the character.
This is one of my favorites.
We also tried a real
time strategy game.
I released the mechanics
around real time strategy game.
So you can click on a
character and then point
and click to move
that character around,
just like you would in a
normal real time strategy game.
A gesture on the controller
is used for an action
there, to make the dragon sing.
Then here is the
touchpad is actually
being used to create a
drag rectangle to select
multiple characters and
then move them around.
And they go back to
selecting one at a time
as they try to solve the puzzle.
Another thing the
controller is great at
is flying, where the
controller maps to the objects
that you're having fly around.
This is also a good example
of keeping the user grounded.
So if the camera
was flying forward,
that can be some
somewhat disorienting.
But because they're
controlling the kite,
and user still
stands on the ground,
and we have these big
pillars next to them,
they don't have as
much of an effect.
And they can still
have all the fun
of flying while feeling like
they're grouted themselves.
So trying a little
kite was interesting.
And this is also, the
kite itself is on a plane.
But we wanted to explore
flying more in 3D space, still
with the same notion of control.
And this next one
is actually inspired
by how kids play with toys.
As you sort of gesture with
the toy, and toy flies around.
Where here, as you
move the controller,
you're controlling
this massive dragon.
And especially in
VR, as you look up
you get a really interesting
sense of scale here.
All right, so in
conclusion, when
you're thinking about users,
thinking about 30 minute plus
sessions of using
your application.
This is not snackable as
much as it's a full meal.
And what we're finding in
terms of these actual play
sessions in our
market research is
it's really how engaging an
immersive the content that
dictates how long the
user's playing the session.
Whereas with mobile
phones, usually something
else distracts them.
They need to get off the
subway, or their friend
has just come back, if
you're seated in a cafe.
In VR, there's nothing
to distract them.
It's more like they're
in their reading nook,
and they're fully
engaged and immersed
in what you're creating.
So if you create a long
form, story, narrative
driven content, users
are going to love that.
And they're going to be
really lost in the worlds
that you make.
Or if you have
incredibly engaging
gameplay, really good sword
gameplay mechanics, or a really
fun tennis game.
Users can equally
be just as immersed
in that for very
long periods of time.
In terms of ergonomics,
think about all the things
that Mike presented in
terms of constraints.
Also do a lot of testing
on your own applications
to make sure that
everything's working.
And you really want to base
your design around these metrics
so that the user's as
comfortable as possible.
For the environment, think
about what emotion you
want to evoke in your users.
How that emotion sort
of ties into your brand.
You can take the users
anywhere, so there's really
an infinite canvas of
what you can create,
in terms of the experience that
you want users to have as they
engage with your applications.
Then finally, with
the controller,
there's an incredibly
broad gesture vocabulary.
This is just some of the
things that we've shown.
We hope you find them
inspiring as you craft apps.
And everything's open sourced,
so if you build your own dev
kit, and then when
you download this,
you can actually try out
all those applications.
There's a few additional ones
that I didn't show as well.
But as you explore the
capabilities of the controller,
we're also really excited
to see what the development
community comes up.
Because there's really a lot
packed into this controller
as to how you can use it.
All right.
So with that, thank you.
And we'll be happy to take
questions after the session.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]